pero la gente sale del territorio porque
necesita seguir existiendo y seguir
existiendo lo que somos como comunidad y
sale de su territorio también porque
necesita preguntar otras voces el salir
tiene doble intención es salvaguardar la
vida pero también decir me salía y algo
haya generar una alerta
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero menos reciente que antes no se veía
es que esos grupos armados se asientan
dentro de las comunidades e incluso
camuflados y armados consiguen casas en
el medio de la población no tienen
campamentos como antes y eso es un
factor de vulnerabilidad que hace que
algunos se desplazan
[Música]
y llegaron disparando
destacando a la gente los de las casas
los niños
fue algo
triste duro porque
dejar uno su territorio y venir a pasar
necesidades acá es como bastante crítico
[Aplausos]
[Música]
tenemos esperanza en el modo presente
que ojalá pues
cumpla y prometa que no solamente es
prometer hay que prometer y hay que
cumplir y es mejor no prometer y cumplir
[Aplausos]